إينولا يا عزيزتي في الثامن من كانون الثاني (يناير) أطلقت
القوات الحكومية في مسكنها النار على عمليات غير مسلحة
، فتى مراهق محمد الفاتح
هو من بين أول من ماتوا
تخبرنا والدته أنه كان يعلم أن هناك فرصة لقتله في
ذلك اليوم قريبًا.
تمت الإطاحة بالبشير لكن الحشود
لا تزال تتجمع خارج المقر العسكري
اليوم وهم يهتفون فقط
الدماء تغسل الدماء ويريدون العدالة
لعشرات الأرواح التي فقدت خلال
عملية مؤيدة للديمقراطية ، لكن كان من الممكن
أن يحدث ذلك كثيرًا بمجرد أن علمت شبكة سي إن إن ذلك
في يناير  وضع مستشارو الحكومة في روسيا
خططًا لقمع
العملية تقول مصادر حكومية في السودان
إنهم عملوا من مكتب في مسكنها
ينتمي إلى شركة تعدين روسية غامضة
تدعى M انفست مركبات
السيراميك وهو في صنم فينوس - إيريكا روسي
أديلمو جوديان سألنا للتو  في تلك
المكاتب وأخبرونا أن هذه كانت
شركة تعدين أخرى ليست M Investment ولكن
هذا هو العنوان الدقيق
الذي قدمته لنا مصادر عديدة وهناك
بالفعل  ليست أي شركة روسية أخرى
تتطابق مع الوصف الذي حصلنا
عليه بخصوص M Investment هنا
، اكتشفت CNN أن M Investment لديها
خططًا متطورة لتعطيل
العملية التي تصورها على أنها مؤامرة أجنبية
ملفقة دليلًا على أن العمليات التي
تم دفعها كانت تدمر
المساجد  والمدارس ، تأتي الأدلة
من آلاف المستندات التي شاركناها
معنا من قبل
مركز ملف الجهير ، فهم يرسمون
صورة لعملية مستعدة للذهاب
إلى أبعد الحدود للحفاظ على America Shearer في السلطة
ولكن لماذا تهتم شركة التعدين الغامضة
لأن em Investment جزء من
إمبراطورية أعمال لك فيرجيني ،
أحد أبرز الأوليغارشية في روسيا
ورجل مقرب من
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ، ولم تقدم الوثائق
التي استعرضتها سي إن إن أي تأكيد على
أن الأجهزة الأمنية الروسية الرسمية
كانت متورطة بشكل مباشر في محاولة
قمع العملية في السودان ولكن السودان
كان في  قلوب المسعى الروسي
لتوسيع نفوذها في أفريقيا
روسيا راهنت بشكل كبير على عمر  البشير أراد
مساعدة لوجستية للبحرية في
بورتسودان في يناير / كانون الثاني ، تداول نشطاء
صورا لرجال مدججين بالسلاح
يراقبون العملية
وتقول مصادر حكومية وعسكرية في السودان إنهم
متعاقدون روس خاصون مرتبطون
بقوات الحكومة السودانية ،
وأوصوا بأن على من يُطلق عليهم الخاسرون.  يتم
إعدامهم بتجميع حملة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تشير إلى أن إسرائيل كانت
وراء العملية وتقول إن
النشطاء المثليين وثنائيي الجنس كانوا
يعملون بين المتظاهرين وهو أمر
كان من الممكن أن يكون غير
مقبول تمامًا في المجتمع الإسلامي والمحافظ بعمق
هنا في السودان
مصادر حكومية وعسكرية متعددة
في السودان ، أخبر CNN أن المستشارين الروس
تم تعيينهم في الوزارات الحكومية وجهاز
المخابرات الوطني
وفقًا لأحد كبار الشخصيات في
نظام البشير ، حيث تضمنت خططهم
ما وصفه بخسائر ضئيلة في الأرواح ولكنها مقبولة ، حيث
بدأ النظام في
تنفيذ خطة M Investment لتلطيخ
الطلاب.  محاولة  لتأجيج الحرب الأهلية التي
تحد من الوصول إلى الإنترنت وحتى
ابتكار حملة وسائط اجتماعية وهمية
لبدء النزاعات والمعلومات المضللة ، نفس دليل القواعد في
الولايات المتحدة.  يقول المدعون إن
وكالة أبحاث الإنترنت الروسية
اعتادت تعطيل الانتخابات الرئاسية لعام 2016 ،
فإن الوكالة و M انفستمنت كل من
TF Genie Prague Ocean
كان قد نفى سابقًا أي علاقة
بالتدخل في الانتخابات ولم يتم الرد على مكالمات لشركته من أجل
هذا التقرير وعندما
شعر على ما يبدو أن حكومة السودان كانت
بطيئة  من الواضح أن بروغ المحيط أراد
المزيد في رسالة إلى البشير في منتصف
مارس ، واتهم الحكومة
بالتقاعس وحذر من أن عدم وجود خطوات
فعالة للتغلب على الأزمة من المرجح أن يؤدي
إلى عواقب أكثر خطورة حيث
اكتسبت العملية قوة بالنسبة لجاسان.  كتبت
مرة أخرى مشيدة بالبشير كقائد حكيم
وبعيد النظر ، لكنها حثت على
إجراء إصلاحات فورية ، أخبرنا كبار المسؤولين في مسكنها
أن الآلة ترددت في غضون
أسبوع رحيله ، لكن
المستندات التي استعرضناها ليست M انفست تظهر أن
لديها علاقات وثيقة لمعرفة أوجه القصور  العسكريون
وهم المسؤولون الآن
عائلات الشهداء يصلون أن تضحياتهم
ليست هباءً على الرغم من أن الله  ح
قد يكون لدى الكرملين وأعضاء حكمه
أفكار أخرى ولكن في الوقت الحالي هنا في مسكنها
يستمر الكفاح من أجل الحرية نيرمال
بابا CNN الخرطوم السودان